bonjour à toutes et à tous les invités
de ça au caddie ce matin raymond
occolier bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
maire du vauclin vous avez décidé de ne
pas vous représenter en 2020
vous avez l'air soulagé soulagé vous
avez le sens de l'humour bien ça faisait
30 ans que j'étais que je suis toujours
servi de la population du voka la
population martiniquaise est aujourd'hui
maintenant je vais entrer dans une
nouvelle saison de ma vie qu'est ce qui
a motivé votre choix mais je viens de
vous dire ça fait trente ans plus chauds
servis de la population est là qui sont
là depuis plus longtemps et ça c'est
leur problème moi je parle pour moi
aujourd'hui je considère que j'ai
d'autres d'autres missions notamment sur
le plan spirituel tout le monde le sait
d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais caché
vous et moi nous allons mourir un jour
c'est bien joli d'avoir un travail une
femme une maison une voiture mais nous
pouvons mourir n'importe quel moment
vous et moi aujourd'hui ne sait pas
alors sa mort ça vous arrive est si si
dieu n'existe pas le problème est réglé
nous sommes poussier éternellement mais
si dieu existe c'est terrible deux
parties pendant l'éternité loin de lui
sans avoir fait la paix avec lui là des
questions fondamentales qui interpelle
tout être humain qui nous regardent et
une écoute est que je répète ma question
est ce que vous pensez à la mort est ce
que cela vous obsède parce que vous avez
écrit un livre et vous vous en parlait
comme visiter votre testament
est-ce que cela l'amour vous obsède ça
ne m'obsède pas c'est un passage obligé
c'est ce que je vous dis c'est la porte
vers l'éternité
et c'est une question qui nous
interpelle tous nul ne sait ni le jour
ni l'heure
c'est vrai que cet ouvrage en quelque
sorte c'est mon testament politique
parce que j'ai tourné la page avec toute
la politique politicienne que j'ai connu
au cours des 40 dernières années
alors on reviendra sur ce livre georges
clément a été désigné par l'union
démocratique vous nouveau clip noise
pour mener la liste en 2020 et pourtant
2014 vous aviez déclaré qu'il n'était
pas question de laisser la ville à ceux
qui n'ont pas la crainte de dieu ce sont
vos propres mots et aujourd'hui vous
partie alors que
rien n'a vraiment changé ce sont les
mêmes protagonistes qui était déjà prise
en 2014 qui se retrouvent aujourd'hui
pour deux pour les municipales de 2020
georges clients de côté et votre vie
votre premier adjoint et vote reposent
en fait un au delà il ya quelque chose
qu'on n'ait pas saisi c'est qu'à
l'époque georges cléon
quand je lui proposer de prendre le
reprendre le flambeau il ne veut ni ne
voulait pas aujourd'hui c'est différent
il a accepté donc le problème est réglé
bon vous parlez de l'opposition je
parlais de gens effectivement qu'ils
avaient des pratiques fort etranje
autour de la les campagnes électorales
ce sont des pratiques j'ai combattu tout
le monde qu'on pensait que de quoi je
veux parler nous sommes des martiniquais
je suis à dire vous avez réalisé votre
une opposition de faire quoi je suis un
chrétien il ya des pratiques auxquelles
avec lesquels je ne suis pas du tout en
harmonie c'est à dire l'homme est
précise et aller jusqu'au bout puisque
vous parlez en vérité aller jusqu'au
bout l'opposition fait quoi je vous ai
dit qu'il ya des pratiques avec lesquels
je suis en total désaccord je parle non
seulement des pratiques qui visent qui
vise a insultés diffamés la majorité
municipale
et puis il ya des gens qui font des
choses étranges que sa date depuis
longtemps autour de certaines personnes
certaines personnes de l'opposition
il ya des gens qui font des pratiques
liées à commanditer des choses étranges
autour des si métiers des choses comme
ça ça n'a rien à voir avec la politique
que je défends est ce que quand on est
opposant on n'a pas le droit de
critiquer bien sûr c'est le wall de
l'opposition mais l'opposition a pas de
faire la diffamation et nous étions dans
et nous sommes toujours très souvent
dans la diffamation permanence raymond
occolier ce que 2014
au moment où vous dites oui je non je
n'y vais pas et puis ensuite oui j'y
vais est-ce que ce n'était pas du
cynisme de la manipulation c'est parce
que vous faites semblant de ne pas
comprendre ce que j'expliquais très
clairement j'ai dit que je partais la
population vous le savez n'a pas
souhaité que je parle et autour de ma
demande équipe il n'y avait aucun
adjoint qui voulaient continuer m'ont
dit nous sommes arrivés ensemble on part
avec toi si tu t'en vas avec le choix je
ne peux pas laisser la ville entre les
mains de n'importe qui
n'importe qui je veux dire des gens
qu'il n'avait aucun projet qui n'ont
toujours qu'un projet à part la
diffamation permanente donc aujourd'hui
les choses sont tout à fait différentes
mon premier adjoint conseiller
territorial monsieur georges clients il
a accepté de reprendre le flambeau et il
va vers une équipe rénovée avec cette
nombre de jeunes
et puis aussi des anciens qui vont
apporter leur expérience et leur sagesse
voilà la différence fondamentale georges
clés ont donc été choisie cela veut dire
que votre fils n'était pas prêt je ne
comprends pas ce que vous dites on a
beaucoup parlé de votre fils vous
prendre votre succession bien vous ne
pouvez pas empêcher les gens de dire ce
qu'ils veulent
mon fils fait partie de ce groupe de
jeunes qui ont tout à fait la capacité
de main de continuer à faire du vauclin
un espace où le slogan la dignité
retrouvée à la fraternité le progrès
continuent à vivre mais je souhaite
qu'ils continuent à travailler que les
autres jeunes qu'il assume pleinement
ses responsabilités qui prennent le
relais de son père aux gens vous avez
vraiment une obsession la scène
genevoise de questions révolution ne
sont pas des obsessions non c'est une
fusion nous aurons on discute et on ne
voit que je vous répète qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de jeunes dont celui là
qui ont tout à fait la capacité à
reprendre le flambeau
alors vous quittez la mairie mais on
vous reproche aussi à un certain nombre
de choses par exemple de dilapider
l'idée à vos clients à la parcelle par
exemple de lusine à l'entrée du bourg
entre autres
c'est une stupidité une fois ma
stupidité la ville un terrain sur
lesquels nous voulons faire venir
installer une zone d'activités
économiques ou des entreprises vont
s'installer pour donner du travail aux
jeunes afin d'éviter que aussi grand
nombre
tout le monde sait que chaque année 1 à
la martinique il ya environ 4000
personnes qui vont chercher du travail
en europe et aux états unis
nous voulons faire en sorte que l'exode
soit freinée sinon comment faire sinon
en permettant des chefs d'entreprise de
créer des activités économiques c'est ce
que nous voulons faire c'est vraiment un
argument imbéciles
ces essais en vendant grands groupes
qu'on arrive à faire cela monsieur mais
ça n'a absolument aucun sens
anti-économique ce que vous dites il
s'agit pas de vent d'un grand groupe un
petit groupe
il s'agit d'accueillir des chefs
d'entreprise mart
niquet quelle que soit la couleur de
l'eau pas pour créer des emplois pour la
jeunesse vos clips la jeunesse
martiniquaise et les commerçants vos
clients acquis depuis 10 ou plusieurs
années inspiré un bouton pour installer
leur commerce voire leur louis pour
faire de l'artisanat
il ya des commerçants qui racontent
n'importe quoi qui abusent certaines
paires certaines personnes comme vous
par exemple c'est moi qui paie
l'initiative d'aller vers les
commerçants pour les invités à réaliser
par exemple le centre commercial
ils m'ont fait poireauter pendant une
douzaine d'années au bout d'une douzaine
d'années
nous avons pris la décision de
travailler avec des gens sérieux qui ont
les moyens de réaliser le projet est le
projet que nous avons c'est de veiller à
ce que les activités nouvelles soit
installé et que les petits commerçants
qui sont pas tout à fait petit parce
qu'ils ont d'autres commerces dans
d'autres communes
les petits commerçants puissent
bénéficier aussi d'activités nouvelles
que nous allons amener sur le fond de
mettre vos clés en ré oxygéner en
redynamisant le centre bourg dans tout
ça c'est dans une parfaite
la recette parfaite harmonie de
synchronisation autre chose certains
agents de la ville attendent toujours
leur titularisation d'autres des
avancements et ce depuis des années
vous partez ils disent que vous partiez
mais toujours grise attend toujours et
qu'il ne voit rien venir ça aussi c'est
de la diffamation je ne sens pas les
agents qui le disaient les gens qui
disent ça c'est de la diffamation
pourquoi premièrement nous avons
multiplié par six le nombre d'agents
titulaires au vauclin quand nous sommes
arrivés en avait 13 aujourd'hui nous
avons titulariser près de 90 agents
deuxièmement tous les ventes uniques et
qui nous écoutent ça parfaitement que si
nous voulons titularisé je suis pour la
titularisation de tout le monde
je suis pour la titularisation mais faut
dire toute la vérité si on veut
titulariser ça veut dire qu'il faut
augmenter tous les salaires de cartes
poussant chacun sait que les dotations
de l'état diminuent en permanence et que
le vauclin a réussi cette performance
nous sommes parmi les 34 communes l'une
des deux où les impôts sont les plus
faibles à la martinique les taux sont
les plus fermes à la matinée donc ça
voudrait dire qu'il faudrait faire
exploser les impôts de la population
def si nous voulons augmenter tout
séjour de 40 % alors je veux bien le
faire mais que l'on me donne la recette
miraculeuse qui va nous permettre de
titulariser des dizaines et des dizaines
de personnes en masse le seul coup pour
l'instant nous faisons une chose qui est
formidable
voilà des gens qui de la conjoncture
économique extrêmement difficile que
nous connaissons nous nous voyons tous
les jours des entreprises privées qui
met la clé sous le paillasson
tous ces gens qui ne sont pas titulaires
mais ils ont au moins pour la plupart
d'entre eux un contrat à durée
indéterminée ceux qui ne sont pas
titulaires clients permettent d'avoir un
emploi jusqu'à la retraite qui est
garanti au moins cela ne l'avons fait et
cela c'est de la justice sociale alors
vous avez écrit un livre le disais au
début de l'émission qui s'intitule alors
tant pis je dis la vérité
raymond occolier vous aviez quelques
comptes à régler avec eux vous vous vous
ai lu avec des avec les élus avec vos
collègues pensent que vous classez les
ai lues en douze catégories et ayant peu
par rapport à leur motivation et la
première catégorie que vous mentionnez
que vous citez c'est l'argent il ya des
politiques qui espère je sue sitala
espère obtenir un compte en banque bien
garni ensuite il ya la vengeance le
pouvoir et le complexe de supériorité
les élus sont motivées que par l'argent
alors quand vous faites un raccourci
saisissant mais vous citer que cette
promesse la première chose que vous
citez je donne une liste jeudi à douze
catégories
je parle d'un extrême à un autre je dis
qu'à des élus qui de tout temps c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui pourquoi ne pas faire
l'inversé
quand je vous dis je fais comme j'avais
envie de faire ne vous engagez d'abord
montré que d'un côté il y à des élus qui
ont des motivations qui sont assez
curieuse et puis de l'autre côté il y à
des élus qui ont vraiment des idéaux des
motivations qui sont tout à fait noble
alors je vous remercie dont parlait
aussi jeudi qu'ils allaient 2 oui mais
quand vous lit on a l'impression que
c'est d'abord l'argent l'argent la
vengeance le pouvoir qui attire s les
élus massez votre lecture ce n'est pas
la mienne et je ne crois pas que ce soit
la lecture des innombrables lecteurs
puissent comment nous parlons cet
ouvrage dans le top des ventes et les
classant numéro 2 des livres les plus
demandés vous n'êtes pas tendre non plus
avec les indépendantistes
c'est une notion dépassée aujourd'hui
non je ne suis pas méchant avec je dis
simplement qu'aujourd'hui
depuis 1958 il ya des partis qui se
battent pour l'indépendance et que si
enfin une consultation comme celle qui a
eu lieu en 2010 en cas aujourd'hui vous
pouvez que l'immense majorité des
martiniquais n'est pas favorable année
parce qu'il faut se poser la question je
dis qu'il faut avoir une faut prendre le
temps de faire son innocence on analyse
on est respectueux on voit mais pourquoi
les martiniquais dans leur immense
majorité ne souhaite pas l'indépendance
alors que beaucoup de pays dans le monde
sont exigés par les par les gens du pays
c'est tout simplement ce que je dis je
fais une analyse je ne jette la pierre à
personne
quant au drapeau vous étrillé les
partisans du rouge vert noir que vous ne
reconnaissez pas d'ailleurs vous
préférez où je viens devant vous
préférez le rouge vert jaune et vous
fait même une proposition page 62 votre
livre d'un drapeau blanc quand vous ne
m'avez pas compris je ne rejette
personne au contraire au contraire
prenez le temps de lire l'autre mot je
propose un drapeau dans lequel on
rassemble toutes les composantes
pétantes unique et ceux qui veulent le
bleu-blanc-rouge plus ceux qui veulent
le rouge jaune vert plus ceux qui
veulent le rouge vert noir vous voyez et
je mets au milieu de tout ça deux
symboles que tout le monde connaît vous
voyez le colibri le fameux colibri le
coni oui il est sur toutes les plaques
d'immatriculation de tous les
martiniquais
quelles que soient leurs opinions
politiques donc ils se reconnaissent
dedans
deuxième chose que les martinique ont
déjà adopté c'est l'emblème que le
conseil général avait hier les 2000
kitchen la martinie voyez je cherche
être rassembleur fédérateur
raymond collier je vous remercie passé
une excellente journée à l'écouté de nos
programmes